Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Cuando era estudiante de medicina
un profesor nos preguntó
"¿Qué es el infarto agudo de miocardio?"
Y respondimos casi sin pensarlo.
Es la necrosis, la muerte,
del tejido cardíaco.
"Muy bien", nos dijo.
"Pero ¿si el tejido está muerto,
por qué duele tanto?"
Nos quedamos mudos.
Él siguió: "Lo que duele
es el tejido circundante,
lo que está alrededor de lo muerto.
Eso que todavía está vivo.
Si duele, es que está vivo".
Quiero hablar del dolor,
y también del miedo.
Pero veamos una escena
lejos de la facultad
y mucho más cerca en el tiempo.
Algo que pasó hace muy poco,
el 8 de marzo en un grupo de WhatsApp.
Alguien manda un mensaje de saludo
por el día de la mujer.
"¡Feliz Día!"
Las respuestas empiezan a caer.
Algunas en buen tono. Otras no tanto.
Haciendo referencia
al origen histórico de la fecha,
no particularmente feliz.
El tipo -- era un varón --
pide disculpas y enseguida aclara:
"Uds. saben que no soy para nada machista.
Saben desde dónde lo digo.
Aparte, voy a todas las marchas".
Después se llama a silencio.
El tipo que aclara que no es machista,
que entiende las nuevas formas
de organización de las mujeres,
y que acompaña esos cambios,
podría ser cualquiera
de los varones que estamos acá.
Pero esto no nos pasa
solamente a los varones.
Podrían ser mujeres.
Porque lo de atajarnos
es algo que nos pasa a todos.
Cuando sentimos
que podríamos meter la pata,
cuando nos estamos aventurando en asuntos
que están en plena transformación,
nos sale esa especie de aviso,
o advertencia,
para que no nos hagan reclamos
en el futuro.
Es como cuando se publicita una promo
que se escucha esa voz al final que dice
"oferta válida en todo el país,
excepto la Provincia de Córdoba".
Es una suerte de términos
y condiciones que hacemos
para aclarar que no somos retrógrados
y que acompañamos los cambios sociales
que estamos viviendo.
Sería algo así como
aclaración válida para toda situación
en la que tenga que opinar
sobre un tema sensible
sin quedar como un fascista.
¿Se reconocen haciendo ese tipo de avisos?
Cuando los hacemos,
¿no estamos de algún modo
definiendo el tipo de conversación
que queremos tener?
Por ahí queremos empatizar
con la otra persona.
O que esa persona
no nos considere peligrosos.
Por ahí tenemos miedo
de que nuestras palabras
se interpreten justo al revés
de lo que queremos decir.
¿Cuál sería el colmo de esos avisos?
¿Que en un programa de televisión
un periodista le pregunte a una chica
cómo iba vestida cuando fue acosada
y en el zócalo de la pantalla
aparezca el número de teléfono
para llamar en caso
de violencia de género?
Estar de acuerdo con los cambios
no nos libra en principio
de hacer esos avisos.
Hay una especie de resistencia al cambio
que se expresa de varias formas.
Aunque coincidamos, nos cuesta.
A mí, por ejemplo, me cuesta
hablar diciendo "chiques" y "todes".
Lo veo forzado, no me resulta cómodo.
Entiendo y comparto
lo que se busca al hablar así.
Pero no me sale. Al menos por ahora.
Sin embargo,
cada vez me cuesta más escribir
utilizando el masculino plural
extendido a todas las personas.
Entonces, cada vez
tengo más destreza para evitarlo
y uso mucho palabras
que no especifican género,
como "gente", "personas", "alguien".
Pero no lo hago porque está bien
o porque es más correcto.
No me sale ahora de otra forma.
Una vez que lo viste
no podés dejar de verlo.
Y si la forma en que hablamos
o escribimos afecta nuestros vínculos
quizás al ser más inclusivo provoco
menos dolor en algunas personas.
Pero ese "vos sabés
desde dónde te lo digo",
ese aviso del que hablábamos antes,
no es algo que le pasa
solamente a quien lo dice.
Es una experiencia que atraviesa
a todos los participantes
de la conversación.
Y es la expresión del destiempo
que hay entre los cambios
que se van generando
y nuestra capacidad para metabolizarlos.
Pero ¿qué es ese destiempo?
Veamos algunos ejemplos.
Cuando se sancionó
la ley de matrimonio igualitario
y un tiempo después
la ley de identidad de género
¿estábamos preparados para eso?
¿Qué significa estar preparados?
La pregunta misma
de si estábamos preparados para eso
podría resultar ofensiva.
Pero, bueno, Uds. saben
desde dónde lo digo, ¿no?
(Risas)
Pero ¿por qué podría resultar ofensiva?
Imagínense que estamos en Múnich.
Es el 2 de octubre de 1946.
Ayer terminaron los juicios de Núremberg.
Quiero entrar a un café y me dicen que no,
que me piden disculpas
pero que todavía no están preparados
para recibir judíos en su establecimiento.
Que están de acuerdo
con todo eso de los juicios
pero que necesitan tiempo.
¿Qué tiempo?
¿Acaso las leyes están para contemplar
lo subjetivo y lo personal?
¿O justamente indican la presencia de algo
que marca el final de un tiempo
y el inicio de otro?
Explicale a alguien
que padeció toda su vida prejuicios,
hostigamiento, discriminación,
que los demás necesitan tiempo.
Aprobamos el matrimonio igualitario
y Uds. hace 25 años que están juntos
pero el personal del registro civil
tiene que procesar esta información.
(Risas)
Pero el asunto es más complejo.
Porque los vínculos, las relaciones,
se establecen entre personas diferentes,
que están en momento diferentes.
Y que experimentan
el amor, la libertad, la igualdad,
de formas distintas.
En mi trabajo como terapeuta trato de ver
qué impacto tienen en nuestros vínculos
algunos de los cambios sociales
de los que somos testigos
y también protagonistas.
Estamos atravesando
un cambio paradigmático,
que a muchas personas
les duele y las violenta,
por resistirse al cambio
o por no tolerar la resistencia
de los que se resisten.
Y junto con el dolor está el miedo,
que también es una señal
de que algo está pasando.
El miedo que muchas veces nos paraliza,
no nos permite avanzar,
también es una alerta de que ahí adelante
hay un problema; que hay que estar atentos
y hacer algo al respecto.
Pero el miedo es una experiencia personal.
En cambio, este dolor
es una experiencia colectiva
que surge como consecuencia
del roce en los vínculos.
Por ejemplo, sienten dolor quienes
se resisten a las nuevas formas del amor
o algunas no tan nuevas,
pero que están siendo muy visibilizadas.
Y sienten dolor quienes
entienden que es inconcebible
que esos cambios todavía
no se naturalicen del todo.
Pero los cambios están ocurriendo.
Y parece que se abre un camino inexorable.
¿Y cuál es el problema?
Si los adultos, especialmente
los que están a cargo de instituciones,
no podemos soportar este dolor
las nuevas generaciones van a perder
eso que pensábamos fundamental.
Esa mezcla de límites y contención,
de afecto y contexto normativo.
Van a perder el alerta.
Quizás los actuales escraches adolescentes
sean entre otras cosas
un síntoma de ese otro síntoma.
La deuda de los adultos
y de las instituciones.
Se vienen épocas en las que
vamos a tener que conversar
sobre cómo conversamos.
Y eso incluye hablar
de avisos y advertencias,
gestos, tonos de voz,
escuchar a los demás,
registrar las tensiones
y el matiz del conflicto.
¿Cómo van a ser nuestras conversaciones
en un futuro cercano?
Imaginen conversaciones difíciles,
pero no incómodas,
respetuosas pero no políticamente correctas,
conversaciones que causen menos dolor.
¿Qué leyes, qué palabras, qué preguntas
que hoy ni imaginamos harán falta?
¿Y cuáles que hoy existen
no tendrán más sentido?
En nuestras discusiones
y en la conciencia del destiempo
está presente el dolor.
Reconocerlo a tiempo y ponerlo en palabras
es sabernos parte de un tejido,
que si duele está vivo.
(Aplausos)